[Musique]
une cérémonie traditionnelle adaptée à
des circonstances exceptionnelles
un discours du trône prononcé devant une
foule réduite et dignitaires masqués et
des chefs de partis absent à tête de la
coved 19 rarement toutefois l'humanité
at elle fait face à un ennemi comme
aussi insidieux le gouvernement trudeau
envoie un signal clair l'heure n'est pas
à l'austérité
l'aide est là pour rester le
gouvernement veut que le programme de
subvention salariale aux entreprises
soit prolongé jusqu'à l'été 2021 le
régime d'assurance-emploi inclurait plus
de canadiens quand la prestation
canadienne d'urgence viendra à échéance
le gouvernement veut aussi créer un
million d'emplois grâce à des incitatifs
et des investissements pour offrir plus
d'expérience professionnelle rémunérée
au jeune canadien l'an prochain de
l'aide pour aider les femmes à retourner
au travail
il est plus important que jamais de
disposer de possibilités de garde souple
pendant l'école où la promesse de bâtir
un système de garde d'enfants inspiré du
québec à l'échelle du canada
sur le front de la santé les libéraux
n'hésite pas non plus à s'immiscer dans
la sphère des provinces
ottawa veut améliorer les efforts de
dépistage investir dans les soins de
longue durée et établir des normes
nationales les libéraux mais tiennent
leur promesse d'un régime national
d'assurance médicaments fidèle à sa
marque de commerce
justin trudeau promet une relance verte
emplois verts rénovation énergétique
transports en commun véhicules
électriques et des cibles climatiques
encore plus ambitieuse un plan qui
permettra de surpasser les objectifs
climatiques du canada pour 2030
combien coûtera cette vision il faudra
attendre une mise à jour économique cet
automne pour voir les premiers chiffres
ottawa ne fixait pas un cadre précis de
contrôle des dépenses entre dattes
promet d'être guidés par la prudence est
de trouver de nouvelles sources de
revenus les géants du web empoche
l'argent des canadiens et imposent leurs
propres priorités
les choses doivent changer dans ce
parlement minoritaire
l'opposition est elle convaincue
conserver
tori bloquiste annoncent leur intention
de voter contre ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est lancer le canada
encore une fois dans des dépenses qui
vont être payés par nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants la fameuse ingérence la
santé est une compétence des provinces
et du québec mon but c'est de toujours
me battre pour les gens le npd négocié
la survie du gouvernement en posant de
conditions détenir des programmes dead
ou si généreux pour les travailleurs
sans emploi et des congés de maladie
payés pour les personnes touchées par la
coved 19
mon but ce n'est pas de trouver un façon
de faire plonger le pays dans une
élection justin trudeau sait qu'il devra
affronter l'électorat
tôt ou tard si le prétexte de ce
discours du trône était la crise
sanitaire
il a aussi été l'occasion pour lui de
jeter les bases de sa prochaine
plateforme électorale ici louis blouin
radio canada